[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur
l'antenne de lcp public sénat pour ce
nouveau numéro de parlement hebdo
l'essentiel de la semaine politique et
parlementaire nickel bonjour bonjour
katia notre invité cette semaine cécile
duflot bonjour député écologiste de
paris soutient benoît hamon beaucoup
d'actualité pour vous bien sûr cette
semaine on parlera de la charge de
françois fillon qui évoque un cabinet
noir à l'elysée autour sur le premier
débat devant les caméras avec les
candidats et puis on reviendra sur la
loi allure que vous avez porté en 2014
aux allures sur l'accès au logement
c'est notre séquence par le mort est
trop mais d'abord on commence par ce qui
devient le fait de la semaine la charge
de françois fillon contre l'elysée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
invité de l'émission politique sur
france 2 le candidat de la droite a
dénoncé un cabinet noir organisé à
l'elysée chargée d'organiser des fuites
contre lui écoutez je vais mettre en
cause le président de la république il
ya un livre qui sort ces jours-ci donc
j'ai pu lire les bonnes feuilles
un livre sur le ministère de l'intérieur
et la place beauvau qui en 240 pages
explique comment françois hollande fait
remonter toutes les écoutes judiciaires
qui l'intéressent à son bureau ce qui
est une illégalité totale
on cherchait un cabinet noir on l'a
trouvé le cabinet noir
en tout cas à travers ces allégations et
moi ce soir solennellement je demande
qu'il y est une enquête ouverte sur les
allégations qui sont portées dans ce
livre parce que c'est un scandale d'état
ce sont des accusations graves
cécile duflot vous avez écouté cette
édition les propos de françois fillon
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ceux qui
croient que ce ne sont pas des actes d
accusation je pense que c'est une
combine une méthode c'est à dire que
vous voyez que françois fillon se et
dans une nasse où effectivement semaine
après semaine on révèle qu'il est le
contraire de ce qu'il avait fait croire
c'est à dire un homme honnête engagée
pour l'intérêt général comme il est
coincé
il invente un peu façon tron pour façon
d'autres un une énormité encore plus
grosse et comme ça alors exactement
c'est la fameuse formule de pasqua si
vous êtes pris dans une affaire inventé
une affaire dans la sphère puis une
affaire dans la sphère dans la sphère à
la fin les gens seront perdus ni
comprendre faire diversion aussi oui
c'est plus que diversion c'est de la
combine c est ce que l'instrument roi
lion c'est de la manipulation c'est la
manipulation la meilleure preuve c'est
qu'on en parle ce matin c'est à dire
qu'on nous on se dit pas est ce que
c'est normal qu'un candidat à la
l'élection présidentielle dans notre
pays soit sous le coup d'une mise en
examen pour abus de bien social
escroqueries aggravées et manquement à
l'obligation de déclaration faux et vous
vous imaginez l'énormité quand même pas
ce qu'il dit il parle d' embaucher sa
femme ce qu'on me reproche pas
d'embaucher sa femme séquelles il l'a
payé présomption d'innocence
oui mais la question n'est pas la
présomption d'innocence la question est
justement que les faits ont été
suffisamment grave pour qu'il soit mis
en examen si vite vous imaginez que les
magistrats du parquet national
financiers sont quand même très
prudent on parle d'un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle donc le
dossier doit être extrêmement béton pour
oser prendre une telle décision ça c'est
le premier élément mais ce que je
voudrais dire justement c'est que parmi
les éléments positifs de ce quinquennat
figurent la création du parc national
financiers c'est la conséquence de la
sphère cahuzac où on avait bien vu que
quand vous avez des révélations de cette
nature sur un ministre vous êtes
embrouillé dans des procédures on ne
sait pas qui doit les lancers là
maintenant les choses sont claires
ça va très vite et ça permet de savoir
madame en une vraie guerre entre amis au
parti socialiste cette semaine vous
demander à ce que nos candidats filles
on se retient
moi je pense qu'il aurait déjà dû se
retirer et on voit bien que la situation
est et là où il est d'une mauvaise foi
ultime moi je suis pas dans les petits
papiers d'alain juppé mais quand il dit
si alain juppé avait été candidat
peut-être que j'aurais pu y montrent de
façon éhontée et je pense que c'est le
problème principal qu'ont avec françois
fillon
c'est qu'il a une espèce de capacités
aux mensonges serein montpellier et oui
pas pour autant bien sûr et vous savez
il a dit à propos de ces enfants avocats
qui avaient travaillé occasionnellement
s'est rendu compte qu'ils avaient des
contrats et qu'en plus il reverser une
partie de leur argent à leurs parents ça
c'est pas une question de présomption
d'innocence c'est un fait établi
donc on a je crois que la droite a un
problème avec avec ce qu'on dit mais si
jamais il devait être élu président de
la république ça donnerait quoi selon
vous d'abord vous est ce que vous
imaginez comment nous regarde à
l'étranger censad que je crois qu'il n'y
a pas un pays où ça peut arriver que
soit vous avez des pays complètement
corrompu du coup la justice ne bouge pas
soit vous avez des pays et j'espère que
c'est le mien où la justice fait son
travail et du coup ben il ya une
élection les procès vont aller voter si
jamais il est élu président de la
république
la haye les poursuites judiciaires
seront suspendus mais celle contre son
suppléant contre son épouse contre ses
enfants se poursuivent enfin j'ai du mal
à imaginer d'ailleurs la réelle donc lui
dira si on lit l'immunité parlementaire
sur l'euro présidentielle vous voulez
dire oui bien sûr et ça je pense que
c'est un rendez vous manqué il fallait
réformer le statut du président de la
république on voit bien qu'on aboutit ou
si on se dit que peut-être monsieur il
veut être présent la république
justement pour que les poursuites soient
suspendus comme marine le pen d'ailleurs
qu'il a dit andrew oui je me présenterai
chez les juges après mon mandat mais qui
ça a quel sens des affaires mais aussi
cette semaine pour
pour un ministre pour bruno le roux il a
dû lui aussi démissionné pour avoir
embauché ses enfants comme
collaboratrice parlementaire
écoutez sa réaction ma responsabilité
est aussi de préserver totalement
l'action gouvernementale c'est pourquoi
j'ai adressé au président de la
république ma démission
celle ci me permet sans autre
considération que ce que je suis en tant
qu'homme et en tant que père de famille
d'affirmer clairement mon honnêteté
mon attachement à la vérité et à une
république dont j'ai toujours essayé de
défendre les valeurs ce que je
continuerai bien entendu à faire je vous
remercie
alors sur ce cas de bruno le roux
certains parlent de dons de démission
éclair mais aussi de démission politique
quel est votre sentiment
mc c'est normal c'est normal vu les
circonstances c'est normal vu la réalité
de ce qui est dit mais ce qui est
surtout pénible et je le dis ici dans
les chaînes parlementaires en tant que
parlementaire c'est la suspicion qui
pèse sur surtout les parlementaires mais
sur du coup sûr tous les hommes et les
femmes politiques
oui donc tout le monde a le sentiment
que c'est un peu le mode de
fonctionnement habituel
moi j'ai trois enfants j'ai quatre
enfants mais dont 300 adolescents
ça m'a jamais traversé l'esprit de leur
région à embaucher dans ce nom mais je
vais vous dire c'est même pas que
c'était interdit s'était pas interdit ça
ne m'a pas traversé l'esprit
voilà françois fillon dans l'émission
bière et dif est le cas de centaines de
parlementaires
donc il a ajouté une forme de suspicion
exactement et je pense comme les cff a
de toute façon maintenant le principe de
françois fillon vous savez c'est un peu
comme la sèche quand elles essayent de
fuir et qu'elle crache un nuage d'encre
voilà donc peu importe la vérité ils
essayent de se cacher mais c'est vrai
que c'est vrai que c'est très pénible
cette suspicion jeter sur l'ensemble des
parlementaires moi je suis favorable
comme le groupe écologiste a été à une
plus grande transparence au fait que les
frais soient remboursés sur notes de
frais je vais vous dire une chose qui
moi même alerte
j'ai entendu la proposition d' emmanuel
macron de dire qu'il fallait fiscalisés
lierre fm l'indemnité européen
mais ça veut dire en creux qu'on accepte
que lire fm ne soit pas utilisé pour
rembourser des frais et que ce sont un
complément de rémunération pour les
parlementaires
et ça a fait tiquer personne mais moi ça
me choque beaucoup soit c'est une
indemnité pour les frais et auquel cas
c'est logique et puis d'ailleurs on peut
les justifier on lire en bourse comme
dans n'importe quelle entreprise soit
c'est un complément de rémunération mais
là cette hypocrite cécile duflot a
avancé un petit peu on va parler des
débats qui ont eu lieu cette semaine et
notamment du débat télévisé entre cinq
candidats hexion présidentielle regarde
ça avec la victoire
donc l'idée qui est des policiers sur le
terrain oui la police de proximité la
prévention c'est plutôt la police
municipale et je considère que dans cet
esprit il faut abaisser la majorité
pénale à 16 ans dans mauvaise idée à mes
yeux on a une justice des mineurs
elle permet des mesures qui sont
coercitives elle permettre de la
contrainte pénale dès l'âge de 10 ans si
le juge l'estimé nécessaire et je pense
que à cet égard il est important de
laisser cette liberté aux juges
et moi je l'assumé je suis pour la
suppression des aides sociales aux
parents de mineurs récidivistes
lorsque les parents ont fait preuve de
carence éducative
nous n'avons pas été à la hauteur de
l'hospitalité que nous devions à l'égard
des réfugiés
c'est la raison pour laquelle je veux un
visa humanitaire qui permettent d'éviter
ces drames que nous connaissons
méditerranée veut arrêter l'immigration
c'est clair et j'assume totalement mon
propos je veux arrêter l'immigration
légale et illégale dans les flux de
migrants qui continuent à arriver qu'ils
vont continuer à arriver à s'aggraver
des terroristes se sont glissés de
faut-il faire arrêter les traités
commerciaux qui dévastent les économies
des autres pays
arrêter les guerres et on peut arrêter
les guerres quand on a décidé de les
faire arrêter
c'est à dire quand on fait discuter les
belligérants prendre en charge ensemble
les conséquences du changement
climatique
voilà comment je vois la solution elle
est rationnel tout le reste sont des
histoires
moi je souhaite demain qu'à partir de 18
ans jusqu'à votre retraite vous puissiez
bénéficier d'un revenu universel
d'existence complément de votre salaire
ou revenu quand vous n'avez rien cela
changera la vie de qui de toutes celles
et ceux qui aujourd'hui vivent
péniblement d'un travail qui ne leur
permet pas de vivre correctement avec
monsieur avancé 32 heures le revenu
universel dans un pays qui à 2200
milliards de dettes enfin voilà ces cinq
cent mille fonctionnaires en moins c'est
bien que ces promesses là ne peuvent pas
être tenues je suis favorable à ce que
le travail paye mieux
je ne suis pas favorable au revenu
universel parce que à la fin quelqu'un
paye l'addition et donc le revenu
universel c'est plus d'impôts il faut
être réaliste
l'idée est belle mais elle n'est pas
raisonnable des n'est pas réaliste
intéressant votre réaction quand on
écoute emmanuel macron face à benoît
hamon pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
réagi avec un petit sourire mais parce
que il ya beaucoup de formules non ce
que dit emmanuel macron mais quand on y
réfléchit deux secondes on voit bien que
c'est creux etc r je vais reconnaître
avec humilité ça fonctionne r que sur
plein de sujets il ne dit rien ou il dit
tout et son contraire ce qu'on appelle
une anthologie en langue française mais
ça fonctionne et l'attique angle on
attrape tout ce qu'on entend les plus en
plus vous savez je n'ai pas de problème
à voir des accords politiques y compris
avec des gens qui sont pas forcément de
la famille ou des désaccords avec
emmanuel macron c'est très difficile
parce qu'il dit tout et son contraire
il est pour la légalisation du cannabis
contre la légalisation du cannabis
et là il vous dit une chose il dit il ya
quelqu'un qui paye a bien sûr et les
impôts
la redistribution la capacité qu'ont à
partager les richesses c'est un choix
dans notre pays en france l'année
dernière c'est le classement de forbes
il ya 39 super milliardaires qui ont
augmenté leurs revenus de 21%
si vous gagnez 20 % de 1 milliard c'est
200 millions c'est le prix d'un hôpital
donc la question est est ce qu'on
partage mieux les richesses dans ce pays
oui ou non ma réponse est oui
donc est ce que ça veut dire réfléchir à
une autre forme d'impôts et dans le
débat d'hier
2pendant dans l'interview de françois
fillon
on a montré quel effet aurait sa
politique c'est-à-dire qu'elle ferait
gagner de l'argent aux plus riches est
beaucoup moins haut moins riches c'est
un choix ça s'appelle la droite c'est le
conservatisme et donc c
mais moi je suis en désaccord avec cette
vision est là quand il dit cela à la
fois il manque aussi beaucoup de
réflexions sur pour une part l'évolution
du travail
la question de la mécanisation de la
robotisation de l'intelligence
artificielle mais surtout la meilleure
du monde regard des règles de dorian va
le rejoindre leur joie à droite certains
le rejoins aussi
oui j'ai regardé d'ailleurs j'ai eu
l'impression que tous les septuagénaires
qui font la politique depuis 40 ans sont
devenus les fans de l'est plus assumer
des manuels macron il ya un truc assez
mystérieux pas dans l'idée de peut-être
qu'ils ont le sentiment que la société
le monde c'est l'écologie ce que je suis
qui le dit en train de changer et qu'ils
ont une espèce de réflexe de
conservatisme de droite ou de gauche
d'ailleurs autour de celui qui
finalement dit pas qu'il va changer dit
qu'il va continuer un peu comme avant
mais je suis assez marquée par l'idée à
la fois évidemment ça a été dit du non
respect des promesses tenues des
engagements mais d'une espèce de crainte
que les choses bougent
ça a l'air de marcher quand même alors
qu'alain anvers benoît hamon est
toujours un peu à la peine en apprend
selon un sondage que plus d'un électeur
sur deux qui dit votait pour benoît
hamon n'est peut-être pas sûr de voter
pour lui
oui ça reste prières faisant c'est un
peu le cas pour tous les électeurs il ya
encore à ma connaissance 35 40 % des
gens qui est sérieux à la paix non
pacifiques devant lui oui mais vous avez
dit je vais vous dire moi je suis pas de
ceux qui critiquent les sondages parce
que je pense qu'il dise quelque chose
notamment sur la question qu'il faut les
prendre en compte mais mais nenê les
sondages que ce soit aux pays bas sur le
résultat des élections même l'avant
veille des élections que ce soit sur les
différentes primaires se sont trompés
donc je pense qu'il faut faire très
attention et surtout il ya un effet
d'entraînement c'est à dire que là il ya
une question démocratique à poser si
l'argument essentiel qui est dit
notamment par monsieur le drian et par
d'autres biais dire face aux risques
marine le pen je vote emmanuel macron
sur quels éléments il se base pour
refaire cette analyse sur les sondages
vous voyez que les sondages deviennent
un élément de décision politique ce qui
leur confère une responsabilité très
lourde finalement alors même qu' on a pu
voir que leur capacité prédictive c'est
d'ailleurs parce que revendus dans le
monde s'était trompé d'un mot benoît
hamon parle de trahison quand jean yves
le drian rejoindre
vous employez les mêmes termes alors
d'abord je voudrais saluer le courage de
benoît hamon parce que l'opération qui
est fait contre lui avec des annonces
successives vous savez les petites
gouttes dit jours après je le fais pour
l'obliger oui oui je pense que c'est
volontaire alors ça vous savez quand
hier s'est organisée quand il ya un qui
s'exprime dans le jdd le dimanche une
autre le lundi et bertrand delanoë qui
fait la matinale de mardi
je pense que enfin je vous savez j'ai
vécu ça cette opération là à l'égard
d'europe écologie les verts donc je sais
john cheever du soleil je pense que les
gens qui sont autour de la candidature
d'emmanuel maquereau ou peut-être
d'ailleurs ceux qui ne veulent pas que
benoît hamon réussissent moi je ne crois
qu'il ya vraiment une partie des
socialistes qui n'ont pas supporté
manuel larimer que la primaire donne
raison à l'analyse de certains dont je
fais partie qui était un désaveu du
tournant qu'a pris quinquennat notamment
en 2014 et que voilà il ya eu un vote ya
une décision et ils n'ont toujours pas
supporté oui mais manuel valls il a
écrit une tribune pour le dire alors
qu'il a signé un papier on voit son
écriture manuscrite autorité des
primaires a contesté ce bruit bien sûr
il ya la volonté de déstabiliser benoît
hamon moi c'est pour ça que je veux
saluer à la fois son courage sa ténacité
et puis son son originalité parce que
vous avez rappelé le débat mais au moins
il dit des choses il fait des
propositions
on sait où sera la france dans cinq ans
si benoît hamon est présent la
république et moi je serais beaucoup
plus rassuré que de dire qu'une
opération marketing a marché même si non
vous avez raison ça fonctionne
j'ai longuement parlé des collectivités
car les candidats à la présidentielle
ont parlé aux maires de france qui
étaient réunis à paris pour l'occasion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les mères qui veulent un nouveau pacte
avec l'êta et entendent être rassurés
notamment sur leurs finances
l'essentiel des discours des candidats
qui sont passés devant eux avec maïté
frémont peine son discours entamé
emmanuel macron et siffler par les
maires sur non moi je viens et je vous
respecte je vous demande simplement la
même chose en cause son idée d'exonérer
la taxe d'habitation pour 80% des
ménages face à la grogne des mères le
candidat dans marche tente de calmer les
esprits en l'état remboursera
directement aux collectivités à l'euro
près ce qui techniquement seront des
dégrèvements de taxe d'habitation sur la
base des taux actuels
deuxième point deuxième point les maires
les maires conserveront leurs pleins
pouvoirs de tous autres candidats
attendus de pied ferme par les élus
françois fillon le candidat de la droite
annonce qu'il procédera à une nouvelle
ponction sur les dotations l'objectif
que je propose
ce serait un objectif pour l'ensemble
des collectivités de baisses de
dotations de l'ordre d'un milliard et
demi par an ce qui ferait 5 7 milliards
et demi sur les cinq ans ramené aux 10
milliards que vous venez de subir sur
trois ans al'inverse nicolas dupont
aignan et benoît hamon s'engage à la
règle de la baisse des dotations tout
comme nathalie arthaud rogner sur ses
dotations et particulièrement cynique
parce que cela permet de faire porter la
popularité de ces décisions sur les mers
qui selon une formule célèbre du
président du sénat sont vieux le site
apporte et d'engueulades
les candidats soutiennent donc les
communes mais leurs avis divergent sur
les efforts d'économies c'est la
première fois que l'association des
maires de france auditionner les
candidats à la présidentielle tous
avaient répondu présent à l'exception de
jean luc mélenchon et de marine le pen
tout de même représenté juste une
question cécile duflot sur une
proposition signée emmanuel macron qui
qui fait débat il veut réformer la taxe
d'habitation ça pèse lourd pour
certaines communes est ce que c'est une
bonne idée ou est ce que c'est un sujet
à risque
non il veut là des grives et c'est à
dire la rembourser moi je pense que ce
qu'il faudrait c'est changer les bases
c'est faire cette réforme nécessaire
on sait très peu de choses ont été un
impact oui l'idée c'est de dire aux gens
vous allez gagner de l'argent avec moi
si vous m'élisez par an le message il
est quand même clair je crois que c'est
pas une vision globale de la manière
dont on confie les responsabilités et
les moyens financiers aux communes aux
différentes collectivités
alors on va passer sur un sujet qui vous
concerne c' est notre séquence parlement
rétro on va parler d'une loi que vous
avez porté ici c'était en 2014
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allure accès au logement et à un
urbanisme rénover c'est donc la loi du
24 mars 2014 à l'assemblée le texte
instaure notamment de mesures
emblématiques l'encadrement des loyers
je vous propose de revoir les
explications de vote que vous avez tenus
à l'époque oui c'est une loi de gauche
c'est une loi de régulation c'est une
loi qui s'attaquent aux causes
structurelles de la crise du logement
c'est une loi qui produira ses effets
dans les mois et sans doute dans les
années qui viennent c'est une loi qui
fallait faire qui réforme des lois des
années 60-70 auquel on a trop tardé à
s'attaquer c'est une loi qui peut
déranger certaines habitudes et certains
avantages acquis mais c'est une loi qui
sera utile à celles et ceux qui ont
souhaité que cette majorité change ce
qui semblait immuable
l'inégalité face au logement je suis
convaincu qu'elle y contribuera de
manière décisive au fil du temps et je
suis vraiment très heureuse de votre
approbation de votre engagement vous
pouvez compter sur la détermination du
gouvernement et de la ministre du
logement pour continuer à agir pied à
pied contre la crise du logement je vous
remercie
voilà il ya à peine cinq mois après ces
explications de vote et l'adoption de la
loi manuel valls décidé de limiter la
mesure emblématique de la loi lui rend
la limitant donc à paris et lille
décision aujourd'hui contesté par le
conseil d'état écouter ce que disent et
manuel valls
à l'époque dans le secteur du logement
je les dis à l'instant il faut faire
preuve de pragmatisme
c'est notamment le cas en ce qui
concerne l'investissement locatif
les objectifs fixés lors de la création
du dispositif dit duflo le sont que
partiellement rempli
nous allons le modifier en profondeur en
offrant aux investisseurs plus de
souplesse et plus d'opportunités et
cécile duflot donc cette semaine le
conseil d'état a jugé illégale cette
décision manuel valls
ils demandent l'annulation pour excès de
pouvoir vous dites victoire jeudi
victoire et je dis surtout victoire pour
la démocratie parce que en fait vous
avez un premier ministre qui annonce
qu'il n'appliquera pas une loi votée par
le parlement ya quand même quelques
quelques mois après vous explique mon
nom à quelques mois après l'adoption aux
options de partout de la majorité je
rappelle que la loi lurel a été adopté
des communistes
jusqu'à à l'ensemble du parti socialiste
du prg et des écologistes
donc je suis très fier de cette loi pour
une raison simple c'est que voilà j'ai
réécouté mes propos je n'avais pas
écouté depuis lors en dix ans à
s'attaquer aux causes structurelles de
la crise du logement
j'avais aussi eu l'occasion de dire que
le principe d'une mise du logement sexy
elle a bien fait son travail
c'est son successeur ses successeurs qui
en tirera les fruits médiatique force
est de constater que notamment sur la
question du logement social
les annonces qui ont été faites par
l'actuelle mise logements montrent que
les objectifs que nous nous étions fixés
en 2012 son patin c'est rare qu'on
atteigne totalement ses objectifs grâce
à la loi sru est en augmentation et puis
grâce à la mobilisation d'un certain
nombre de financements
et puis sur l'encadrement des loyers je
vais faire une j'ai fait une conférence
de presse avec le maire adjoint de paris
en charge du logement ça fonctionne ça
fait baisser les loyers
qu'est-ce que vous inspire quand il
parle de dispositifs duflot parce que
c'est ce sac alors les là il parle du
dispositif fiscal
mais vous savez ça mériterait un peu
plus de temps mais effectivement on peut
dire que le dispositif qui a suivi qui
portait le nom de ma successeur sylvia
pinel a fait l'objet de plus de ventes
et quand on donne plus d'argent public
quand on enlève les critères sociaux
évidemment que ça marche mieux mais est
ce que c'est normal de dépenser des
milliards d'argent public pour augmenter
la rente de certains je crois pas donc
effectivement le dispositif du flou
comme avant lui le dispositif besson
était des dispositifs qui avaient des
contreparties sociales on a levé ses
contreparties et finalement on fait on
fait du chiffre pas forcément utile
cécile duflot quand vous avez écouté
manuel valls a instauré ce que vous vous
dites quelque part que c'était contre
vous la décision qu'il a prise
on se rappelle des bisbilles de l'époque
oui mais peut-être mais c'était idiot
points quand on est premier ministre on
doit pas avoir des questions
personnelles qui décident de votre
action mais c'est surtout
antidémocratique enfin c'était une loi
c'est une promesse du président de la
république
une loi votée par le parlement qu'il
s'agissait de mettre en oeuvre et
surtout dont on voit l'efficacité
ma plus grande fierté vous savez c'est
con juste avant la présentation du
projet de benoît hamon je prenais un
café dans le bar qui se trouve juste en
face il ya la serveuse qui est venu me
voir en me disant vous avez fait baisser
de mon loyer de 120 euros par mois
franchement ça a changé ma vie et j'ai
une grande satisfaction
la politique c'est ça c'est beaucoup de
débats c'est beaucoup tactiques parfois
mais parfois ça pèse sur la vie c'est
utile sur la vie des gens et j'en suis
très fort c'est que la loi lui on va
survivre à la prochaine législature
ra en tout cas j'espère être là est la
droite contre moi en tout cas ce que
j'espère maintenant c'est qu'il va y
avoir il a manqué au moment de la loi
allure il ya eu beaucoup vous avez
entendu beaucoup de critiques à la fois
sur le fond mais parfois personnelles il
fallait attaquer la messagère donc j'ai
bien vécu cette période où les attaques
étaient violentes contre moi
personnellement mais il manquait un
contre pouvoir citoyen de la part des
locataires même dire que vous avez
entendu
manuel valls et je me répète encore une
fois vous êtes allé voir le président de
la république pour des recettes anti
démocratique j'ai écrit une tribune
enfin vous savez je pense que présente
la république était parfaitement
conscient mais pour être très franches
gta je me souviens très bien j'ai été
estomaqué je trouvais ça tellement
minable en fait fin si si si vraiment un
premier ministre ils ont ça s'entend
d'ailleurs dans le ton de sa voix le
dispostif dit duflo enfin vous voyez
bien mais français du conte à la hauteur
oui mais ce n'est pas à la hauteur on
parle de centaines ce production de
l'industrie a été à la hauteur de la fin
du quinquennat françois hollande moi je
pense qu'il a précipité la chute qui a
eu deux effets d'abord qui empêchait le
président de la république de se
représenter ce qui est quand même assez
inédit et qui lui même d'ailleurs a été
défait lors de la primaire oui il a fait
un choix politique était celui de
crisper ça ma propre majorité de
considérer qu' il allait être plus
autoritaire et qu' il fallait s'aligner
sur ses positions et je crois que
c'était une c'était une grosse erreur
voilà une très grosse erreur
j'aime bien fait avec notre partenaire
du figaro tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
env michaëlle jean ketcha bonjour cécile
duflot on vous a entendu tout à l'heure
critiquer le choix des socialistes qui
n'ont pas rallié benoît hamon après la
primaire vous même vous avez bafoué le
choix de militants c'est le choix des
militants socialistes qui ont investi e
now you mr dans le cadre de la 6e
circonscription de paris qui s'est fait
dire par là mais c'est à dire que vous
n'avez pas respecté le choix des
socialistes je respecte totalement le
choix des socialistes qui ont investi
noël ou mère et qui va devoir se retirer
ga en vertu de l'accord signé avec mais
c'est des choses différentes moi je me
suis pas bien évidemment je suis pas
adhérent du parti socialiste je me suis
pas mêlé d'édition du parti socialiste
est ce que vous n'avez pas l'impression
de bafouer justement ce ce choix qui
avait été fait en préalable pas du tout
la question c'est de savoir s'il y avait
s'il ya un accord qui a permis que j'ai
cru que vous allez me vous avez bafoué
le choix des militants de la primaire
écologiste
donc non il est sociable pas socialiste
mais il ya quand même eu un choix a été
fait oui et ensuite ya eu un choix du
parti socialiste lui même de passer un
accord et d'ailleurs y compris un choix
d'europe écologie les verts et des gens
qui ont participé à la primaire de
soutenir le candidat socialiste
oui mais donc ya pas plus de gens qui
ont bafoué une décision dans un sens que
dans un autre c'est des choses qui
avancent et c c'est un rassemblement qui
se crèvent y avait une candidate qui
avait été désigné démocratiquement elle
ne l'est plus aujourd'hui
on est d'accord que son investiture
comme ça non d'investiture sont une
décision du parti socialiste qui ne me
regarde je n'ai pas à intervenir dans
l'édition du part socialiste que ce soit
dans une dans un sens ou dans un autre
ce qui n'est pas un peu disproportionné
quand même cet accord puisqu'il prévoit
que les socialistes doivent se retirer
les socialistes doivent se retirer en
faveur des écologistes sortant dont fait
partie mais par contre les écologistes
sont investis face à des socialistes
sortants soutient donc le site julien
bat julien bayou qui investit face à ces
bad à goma à paris où alexis braud qui
est conseillé
de monsieur jadot face à stéphane le
foll dans la sarthe aussi situé le camp
fait qu'on soutient un certain nombre de
socialistes dès le premier tour ils vont
donc être le candidat à la fois du part
socialiste et d'europe écologie les
verts je pourrais vous citer d'autres
noms ce qui est bizarre c'est que vous
les ayez pas en tête vous avez
conscience qu'il ya beaucoup de fils qui
vivent très mal encore une fois j'ai
conscience qu'il ya quelques socialistes
qui vous ont parlé qui ont envie de
raconter cette histoire oui qui vivent
mal la victoire de benoît hamon
ça c'est certain et qui vivent mal aussi
une autre histoire c'est qu'il a fait un
choix historique qui pour moi est
beaucoup plus important que ce que vous
essayez de mettre en lumière qui le
choix de dire je ne serai plus jamais
socialiste sans être écologiste
moi je suis une écologiste de gauche et
je pense qu'effectivement si on veut
apporter les bonnes solutions dans sur
une planète où aujourd'hui on voit que
le dérèglement climatique est en train
d'entrer dans une phase hors de tout
contrôle
il faut de nouvelles solutions vous avez
une lecture qui a une lecture partidaire
et peut-être une lecture datés ou de
certains qui sont contrariés moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est quelle solution
politique on propose quelle majorité
politique on va construire
c'est ça qui me tient justement c'est de
maintenir un groupe écologiste à
l'assemblée c'est ça c'est un objectif
qui a été fixée mon objectif c'est que y
est la voix des écologistes qui soit
porté à l'assemblée
mais pour vous dire les choses avec
franchise aujourd'hui quand j'entends
benoît hamon j'ai assisté à la
présentation de son projet j'entends une
voix écologistes il est socialiste et
aux héritiers l'histoire sociale et donc
je vous dis je ne sais pas ce qui sera
écrit sur la suite moi je partage la
campagne le projet de benoît hamon on a
quelques petites différences mais pour
le reste c'est pour ça que vous voyez ça
n'a rien à voir j'ai vécu 2011
est ce que vous dites sur 2011 c'était
un accord de parti à parti il y avait un
compromis il y avait un candidat l'état
dénoncé déjà à l'époque oui par les
mêmes par les marques pas non pas par
moi non par des soupapes départ des
socialistes encore une fois aujourd'hui
se disaient les gens qui s'en tirait un
tas de la part des demandes et des
écologistes qui qui attaque en force
diane jubinville bras nous en tombent
oui mais vous non vous l'entendez pas
partout vous l'entendez chez certains
c'est quand même pas anecdotique pour la
première fois depuis 1969
y a pas de candidature j'allais dire
encartés écologistes à cette élection
présidentielle c'est un événement
politique
et vous savez pourquoi parce que ce
candidat benoît hamon est un candidat
socialiste et un candidat écologiste
donc effectivement on est sur un grand
renouvellement mais que certains et je
pourrais vous donner des noms qui
nourrit votre papier soit extrêmement
fâchées qu'au final ce que j'ai dit en
2014 en quittant le gouvernement dire
que le choix d'une majorité fracturé le
choix de tourner le dos à l'écologie
était une erreur y compris pour les
socialistes et pour le président de la
république
finalement c'était vrai c'est lui au
moment où je le fais on pense que je
suis très ému par dont on pense que je
suis très isolé ou que j'ai un problème
personnel avec le premier ministre
trois ans après la primaire non
seulement fait battre manuel valls après
avoir rendu impossible la candidature du
président la république mais pas par
arnaud montebourg qui incarnait les
valeurs de gauche traditionnelle mais
par quelqu'un qui prend des risques et
qui défend un projet social écologie
sera très rapidement quelques mois sans
que vous ne l'écoutez pas quand je
dirais bien sûr bien sûr qu'elle passe
vous voulez pour les écologistes après
2017 est ce que vous voyez europe
écologie comme un nouveau point d'
équilibre dans une nouvelle
recomposition de la gauche qui puisse
rassembler les communistes la gauche du
ps et c'est moi ce qui m'importe
13 ce qui m'importe c'est qu'on fasse
gagner l'écologie c'est à dire qu'on
apporte des solutions qui nous
permettront et qui permettront aux
enfants et aux enfants de nos enfants a
plus empoisonné avec ce qu'ils mangent à
être en meilleure santé avoir un autre
rapport au travail c'est ça qui
m'importe
et quel que soit le périmètre politique
qui lui permettra en tout cas je serai
une artisane de convaincre seul un autre
combat oui merci beaucoup cécile duflot
d'avoir été l'invité de cette émission
très petit de programmes sa chaîne
parlementaire bonne semaine à tous
[Musique]